I was going to see Gaga true yes I have
to tell you how great that show was she
is maybe the best
performer okay so it was it it was at
MGM Park MGM the theater there and I
don't know how many people have it seats
but it felt like maybe
5,000 which for her is probably pretty
small right yeah and so and she was
doing her Jazz um and she so she had a
full orchest behind her and then her
band I was blown away by forget she's
[__] great songs and and great voice
but I'm not like a I'm not out listening
to Frank Sinatra and Tony Bennett Tunes
that's not what I'm into that's not
really my style of music what she was
singing um she she made everybody there
feel
like she was singing directly to them
she made you feel like you were her best
her best friend it was
was such a
warm
generous
loving
awesome feel in that Auditorium and she
was her voice is perfect really good and
she played a bunch of her hits on piano
by herself rearranged them a little bit
right and they were also look man if you
can get 5,000 people and I bet you out
of those 5,000 and there were some older
people there they were like oh this is
like old school right right right but I
bet you out of those 5,000 and 5,000 is
just a guess I bet you 90% of those
people didn't listen to that type of
music didn't listen don't aren't into
jazz so to Captivate people like
that is so [__] crazy and to make it
feel so personal in such a huge space I
was I was blown away it was a life
changing as a
former a
lifechanging night